Riot finally did it they answered
everyone's prayers and it seems like my
days as a chamber one trick are over in
one of the biggest updates the game has
ever seen they finally addressed the
chamber problem we're talking about some
serious potentially meta-altering Nerfs
here players at basically every level of
the game have felt pain and suffering at
the hands of chamber and some would even
tell you that he ruined the game so is
it finally over is chamber dead
all right so before we get into the
video I just want to let you guys know
that we recently dropped a cream and
black color touch grass hoodie so if you
want to check them out then go to
shop.thescore.com so there's a lot to
unpack with this week's update but we've
gotta start with chamber Riot basically
just [__] massacred my boy Headhunter
now has increased bullet spread after
the second bullet so you can't spam body
shots anymore it's not intentional
okay I'm actually pissed but I want to
talk about Rendezvous because these
changes are easily the biggest Nerf dues
kit Rendezvous now just a single anchor
but with a larger radius you can still
take aggressive Peaks and TP away but
just remember that there's a good chance
you'll actually get traded or run down
by your opponents now as someone who
already had plenty of set places for
both anchor points this change felt the
weirdest to me and I'm definitely not
the only one
wait what oh that's how it works
with this change you pretty much have to
rethink all your previous Rendezvous
spots but luckily Riot removed the
teleport height restriction so you can
still take advantage of any map
elevation there's also no longer an
additional cooldown when recalling his
anchor after teleporting but if your
opponents destroy it then it's now gone
for the remainder of the round with
these changes it actually feels like you
can trade your teammate if they die to a
chamber even if he TPS then he can't be
that far away and now that the fire raid
on his alt has been decreased by 57.5
you can't just keep repeating the same
angle after every shot or you'll die so
don't expect to see [__] like this
anymore
[Music]
oh so absolute catastrophe is yay it
finds perfect timing
annihilates the entire team the salon
has alt also only lasts four seconds now
instead of six and the same goes for the
slow on his trademark and we gotta talk
about trademark because something weird
happened with this update it's almost
like chamber feels like an actual
Sentinel now and it's [__] crazy
because he's pretty much been a duelist
since day one trademark now has an
active range similar to killjoy's alarm
bot when chamber steps out of the range
it's disabled and he can recall it mid
round without needing line of sight this
place is a 30 second cooldown on the
ability after playing chamber on the PBE
last weekend and playing him more the
past few days I can confidently say that
Riot has finally done it he's no longer
the must pick agent that he's been since
his release and as someone who was a
chamber one trick throughout that entire
time I can tell you that this is a good
thing a lot of people would tell you
that chamber just sucked the fun out of
the game and with the buff to killjoy's
alt I think it's fair to say that she's
once again the best Sentinel agent since
breech Aftershock can no longer destroy
her ultimate KJ stonks are rising I
think Cipher probably deserves some more
love but hey at least this is a step in
the right direction I suspect that all
the teams he put their jet players on
chamber for the past year will probably
go back to their old ways and run Jed
alongside killjoy on those maps and I
know some of you aren't as invested in
the Pro scene as I am but I can tell you
right now that these chamber Nerfs will
impact you whether you played him before
or not your ELO is not safe right now
while there are a lot of uh
a lot of chamber one tricks they're
trying to figure out how to actually
play the game properly
so the chamber one tricks that are
actually just lost then they're like
picking jet or they're picking off the
chamber
it's going to be rough right now until
they de-rank because they're going to
d-rank a lot of them so if you were a
useless chamber main like myself then
what do you do well I think a lot of us
will probably pivot towards jet since
she can still hold an OP but thankfully
I do know how to play other agents if
you're willing to play chamber like a
sentinel and sit back and lurk more then
you can probably get away with playing
him on certain Maps but I'm not really
into that I want to go and take duels
but maybe it's time for some of you to
learn to play something new anyways
balance meta will likely see drastic
changes over the next few months plenty
of other agents have been tweaked in
this update and with nurse to Viper and
Buffs to Harbor even the controller meta
might change which I know some teams
will be excited for we love Harbor our
team was experimenting with Harbor he
was actually going to be in one of our
Maps but we you know that they're he's
not allowed so we were kind of bummed
and we had to shuffle
like two days before there was a lot
packed into this update in fact so much
that I don't have time to talk about
everything but there are a couple
smaller things that I do want to cover
the Specter has been nerfed from mid to
long range so the SMG meta seems to be
leaning more towards the Stinger after
its somewhat recent buff your teammate's
utility will no longer destroy most of
your abilities but your opponents
definitely will pretty much every form
of Molotov now destroys your opponent's
utility there's a pretty long list of
abilities that this affects so I
recommend taking a look at the patch
notes if you haven't already but luckily
there's an easy way to test out almost
everything in this update and it's
easily one of the best things Riot has
added this year at this point I'm pretty
bored of Spike rush and replication and
I've always wanted a shorter game mode
that uses the same rule set as unrated
or comp and swiftplay is exactly that
there's still pistol rounds there's only
one Spike to plant there's a proper buy
menu and the first team to five rounds
wins I love Swift play as someone who
hasn't really had a whole lot of free
time lately because I just moved this is
just great I don't have to commit to a
full 40 minute match but I can still get
all of my weeklies done no problem I do
wish that it was first to seven instead
of first to five because it's still
similar length to spike rush but this is
a good start it's only in beta right now
and that's expected to end on January
10th so Riot wants us to let them know
if we like it lastly let's talk about
the Skins initially I didn't really like
them I thought they were kind of boring
but after I actually took a look at them
I thought they were sick the fact that
every time you shoot a bullet ice falls
off your gun I think it's been sick I
also just love the sound of the kill
sounds they're dope
foreign
overall I think they killed it with this
update sure there are some bugs that may
have slipped through the cracks but this
patch is refreshing I know the game was
beginning to feel stale for a lot of
people including myself and now that
chamber is pretty much dead I think that
everyone can enjoy the game again
it's a clip of me dying right there I
like popped a shot off and then like
re-peaked and I was like
[__] tragic I'm gonna get roasted in
the comments but it's okay I think
Cypher still asks personally he's
honestly like a sick agent he was so
much fun to play and then like
killjoy and chamber happened
[Music]